Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. To subvert the tyranny of our execrable government, to break the connection with England, the never-failing source of all our political evils, and to assert the independence of my country, these were my objects. To unite the whole people of Ireland, to abolish the memory of all past dissensions, and to substitute the common name of Irishman in place of the denominations of Protestant, Catholic, and dissenter. These were my means. So those, Tom Holland, are the words of Wolf Tone, and last time on The Rest is History, when we were doing an epic sweep through the interwoven histories of Ireland, England and Britain, we were joined by Paul Rouse from University College Dublin.
感谢收听《历史其余部分》。如果您想收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们广受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。为了颠覆我们那个可恶政府的暴政，为了斩断与英国这个我们所有政治罪恶永恒之源的联系，并宣告我祖国的独立，这些就是我的目标。为了团结全体爱尔兰人民，抹去所有过去纷争的记忆，并用爱尔兰人这个共同的称谓来取代新教徒、天主教徒和异见分子的称呼。这些就是我的手段。汤姆·霍兰，这些就是沃尔夫·托尼的话。在上期《历史其余部分》中，当我们对爱尔兰、英国和不列颠交织的历史进行史诗般的纵览时，来自都柏林大学学院的保罗·劳斯加入了我们。
And it's delightful for us, isn't it, that Paul is back and we're still in the GPO. We're still in the GPO, yes. In the centrepiece of the Easter Rising. So, Paul, welcome back to The Rest Is History. Thanks a million, Dom. I mean, for everybody else, you've been gone for three days. For us, I mean, it's actually three minutes this week episode but we ended last time with the 1798 rebellion wolf tone the interplay of republicanism romanticism
对我们来说，保罗回来了，而且我们依然在总邮局（GPO），这不是很开心吗？我们依然在总邮局，是的。复活节起义的核心地标。所以，保罗，欢迎回到《历史其余部分》。非常感谢，多姆。我是说，对其他人来说，你已经离开三天了。对我们来说，我是说，这周的单集其实才过去三分钟，但我们上期结束时讲到了1798年起义、沃尔夫·托尼、共和主义与浪漫主义的交织
revolution and religion in irish society and the act of union so So Ireland is now part of, as a reaction to that failed uprising, Ireland is now part of a united kingdom of Britain and Ireland. And well, why doesn't it work? Or does it work actually in a way that we perhaps don't appreciate today? Well, there were a lot of attempts to make it work and a lot of really interesting and progressive things happened over the sweep of 120 years but ultimately there was a complete disconnect right at the heart of the active union which was this idea of catholic emancipation and that idea from the very beginning the promise that after the Act of Union Catholics would be allowed
革命与宗教在爱尔兰社会中的作用，以及《联合法案》。所以爱尔兰现在是——作为对那场失败起义的回应——爱尔兰现在是不列颠及爱尔兰联合王国的一部分。那么，为什么它行不通呢？或者说，它其实是以一种我们今天可能没有意识到的方式在运作吗？嗯，为了让它行得通，人们做过很多尝试，在长达120年的时间跨度里，发生了很多非常有趣且具有进步意义的事情，但最终，在《联合法案》的核心部位存在着完全的脱节，那就是关于天主教解放的想法，以及从一开始就许下的承诺，即《联合法案》通过后，天主教徒将被允许
to sit in the Parliament in Westminster and of course this was rejected and it was essentially rejected even though William Pitt supported it So it's the King is it? George III And this goes back to coronations
在威斯敏斯特议会中获得席位，当然这遭到拒绝，而且基本上甚至在威廉·皮特支持它的情况下也被拒绝了。所以是国王吗？乔治三世。这可以追溯到加冕礼
and his coronation oath and his disastrous coronation oath at his disastrous coronation, which we talked about, Dominic, where everyone was falling over and having breakfast and all kinds of shenanigans going on. But actually it has this very, very serious consequence that he refuses
以及他的加冕誓词，他在那场灾难性的加冕礼上的灾难性加冕誓词，我们讨论过这个，多姆，当时每个人都在摔倒、吃早餐，各种乱七八糟的事情在上演。但实际上，这产生了非常非常严重的后果，他拒绝
to allow Catholic emancipation to go ahead. And he was unmoved on it and could not be moved on it. And it was only in the 1820s when Daniel O'Connell, one fascinating figure in Irish history, and we're here in the general post office, the GPO, the seat of Irish revolution. But the street that's outside it is now called O'Connell Street. So tell us about Daniel O'Connell is the liberator. Began, born in Kerry, right down in Carsevine, the furthest part away from here you could possibly be and not be wet. And he came to becipation. The idea, and he founded in 1823 a Catholic association based on the counties of Ireland where they collected things and organised.
让天主教解放得以推进。在这件事上他毫不动摇，也无法被说服。直到19世纪20年代，丹尼尔·奥康奈尔——爱尔兰历史上一个极具魅力的人物——我们现在身处总邮局，即GPO，爱尔兰革命的大本营。但外面那条街现在叫奥康奈尔街。给我们讲讲被称为“解放者”的丹尼尔·奥康奈尔吧。他出生在凯里，就在最南端的卡尔西文，那是离这里最远、却又不会弄湿脚的地方。他来到了解脱。这个想法——他在1823年创立了一个以爱尔兰各郡为基础的天主教协会，他们在那里收集物资并进行组织。
Those counties which had been shired by the English and which are now such an important part of Irish administrative life still. And a huge part of people's identity in Ireland is a county identity. I am from Galway. Far more than in England.
那些由英国人划分了郡界、如今依然是爱尔兰行政生活重要组成部分的郡。爱尔兰人的身份认同中很大一部分是郡的认同。我是戈尔韦人。这比在英格兰要强烈得多。
I mean, it's not vaguely comparable. It really matters in Ireland, doesn't it? It really matters. It really matters. And it matters because of sporting allegiance in the Gaelic Athletic Association, but it matters as a basic thing of constituencies for which people are elected to parliament. It matters for local government all across the place. It is fundamental to identity for very many people in Ireland. So it was organised in that and there were showdowns through the 1820s,
我的意思是，这根本没有可比性。这在爱尔兰真的很重要，不是吗？真的很重要。真的很重要。这之所以重要，是因为盖尔运动协会（GAA）中的体育效忠倾向，但它作为人们选出议员的选区这一基础事物也很重要。它对各地的地方政府都很重要。对于爱尔兰的许多人来说，它是身份认同的基础。所以它是在这种基础上组织起来的，在19世纪20年代期间出现了对峙，
but it ended ultimately when O'Connell, standing for a seat in County Clare and being elected as the MP for County Clare. But of course, then it was up to the government. Right, he can't take a seat.
但最终以奥康奈尔在克莱尔郡参选并当选为克莱尔郡议员而告终。但当然，接下来就取决于政府了。没错，他不能就座。
He can't take a seat, can he? So eventually he sawed him down and in 1829, a Catholic Emancipation bill was passed through the House of Commons. And that is passed by the Duke of Wellington, who is Prime Minister. And the Duke of Wellington is also, in a sense, I mean, he is Irish. I mean, he notoriously said that just because he, you know, being born in a stable doesn't make you a horse. Which is not the strategy. Apparently he didn't say that, Tom.
他不能就座，对吧？所以最终他们妥协了，在1829年，一项天主教解放法案在下议院通过。该法案由时任首相的威灵顿公爵通过。从某种意义上说，威灵顿公爵也是爱尔兰人。我的意思是，他曾有句名言：仅仅因为你出生在马厩里，并不意味着你就是一匹马。但这似乎并不是他的策略。显然他没说过这话，汤姆。
Did he not say that? Apparently this is apocryphal. Is that right, Paul? Yeah, it's apocry he not say that apparently this is apocryphal is that right oh it is apocryphal okay so much about the duke of wellington is but so the duke of wellington is a fascinating example of an irishman who becomes synonymous with britain with british victory britain's greatest general oh and more than that tom he and we'll go there later i will show you the pitch one of the oldest cricket pitches in the world, where the first ever organized cricket match in Ireland was played between the gentlemen of Ireland and the military and the Duke of Wellington was playing in that game. And there was a monument. It gets up even higher in my head.
他没说过吗？显然这是杜撰的。是这样吗，保罗？是的，这是杜撰的。他没说过？显然这是杜撰的，是这样吗？哦，这是杜撰的，好吧。关于威灵顿公爵的传说有很多都是这样的，但威灵顿公爵是一个极好的例子，他是一个爱尔兰人，却成为了英国、英国胜利以及英国最伟大将军的代名词。哦，不仅如此，汤姆，我们稍后会去那儿，我会带你去看那个球场——世界上最古老的板球场之一，爱尔兰有史以来第一场有组织的板球比赛就是在爱尔兰绅士队和军队之间在那里进行的，威灵顿公爵也参加了那场比赛。那里还有一座纪念碑。这在我脑海里的分量更高了。
There was a monument at the space to the city and has been for centuries. And standing tall over its entrance is an obelisk, which is a massive monument to the Duke of Wellington, which was constructed in his honour. And while we're on the subject of monuments, just outside us here was the most famous monument in the city. I say was, because it was Horatio Nelson. Paul, for us, this is a very tragic story because nelson is very much a friend of the rest is history he's probably one of our
那个地方曾有一座城市纪念碑，而且已经存在了几个世纪。矗立在入口处的是一座方尖碑，这是一座为威灵顿公爵建造的宏伟纪念碑，是为了纪念他而修建的。既然我们在谈论纪念碑，就在我们外面不远，曾是这座城市最著名的纪念碑。我说“曾是”，是因为那是霍雷肖·纳尔逊。保罗，对我们来说，这是一个非常悲惨的故事，因为纳尔逊可以说是《历史其余部分》的挚友，他很可能是我们的
favorites i mean one of our two or three favorite historical characters yeah so tom in particular is pumped about nelson and it's a big deal for tom to come to a city that blew up the statue of Nelson. Let's get back to this O'Connell, the Liberator, the Duke of Wellington, the Iron Duke, the man who defeats Napoleon at Waterloo. Are we seeing two sides there of the Anglo-Irish relationship in the 19th century? What you see in Ireland across the whole of the 19th century is a country which is slowly, it's changing. It has people within it who are absolutely loyal to empire, who are extremely happy to be part of the United Kingdom. Including Catholics. A very certain class of Catholic ordinarily, but the broad suede of the population were rural and extremely poor. That will come to be of enormous significance later in the century.
最爱之一，我的意思是，是我们两三个最喜欢的历史人物之一。所以，汤姆对纳尔逊尤其充满热情，对汤姆来说，来到一个炸毁了纳尔逊雕像的城市是一件大事。让我们回到这位奥康奈尔——解放者，以及威灵顿公爵——铁公爵，这位在滑铁卢击败拿破仑的人身上。我们在19th世纪的英爱关系中看到了两面吗？你在整个19th世纪的爱尔兰看到的是一个正在缓慢改变的国家。它内部有些人对帝国绝对忠诚，对成为联合王国的一部分感到非常高兴。其中包括天主教徒。通常是某一特定阶层的天主教徒，但广大民众是农村人口且极其贫困。这将在本世纪晚些时候变得具有极其重大的意义。
A lot of them joined the British army. Yeah, there was huge Irish recruitment to the British army. And this is sometimes presented as evidence of being comfortable with an empire and evidence of identification increasingly with what is the army of the empire. But of course it's rooted often in poverty. Now there are people who join the army for adventure and for excitement or to get away from home or for all the many reasons why people do everything. It's very often very difficult to judge that, but there's epic poverty across rural Ireland and urban Ireland too.
他们中有许多人加入了英国军队。是的，大量爱尔兰人应征加入了英国军队。这有时被视为适应帝国的证据，也被视为对帝国军队认同感日益增强的证据。但当然，这通常根源于贫困。当然也有人为了冒险、刺激、为了离开家，或者出于人们做任何事情的种种原因而参军。要判断这一点往往非常困难，但在爱尔兰农村乃至城市，普遍存在着惊人的贫困。
And there's a certain... And Ireland at this point, so the early 19th century, has about half the population of Great Britain. Is that right? Yes. So the population of Ireland grew from about 3 million in 1750 to on the eve of the famine in 1845, it had risen to about 8.4 million. Yeah. And the famine, perhaps even more than Cromwell's invasion, is perhaps the kind of the darkest blot on the history of Anglo-Irish relations. You cannot talk or understand modern Ireland in any shape or form without understanding the famine. You must understand it from what it did in cultural terms, in economic terms.
还有某种……而爱尔兰此时——也就是19世纪初——大约拥有大不列颠一半的人口。是这样吗？是的。所以爱尔兰的人口从1750年的大约300万，增长到1845年大饥荒前夕的约840万。是的。而饥荒，也许比克伦威尔的入侵更甚，可以说是英爱关系史上最黑暗的污点。如果不了解饥荒，你就无法以任何形式谈论或理解现代爱尔兰。你必须从它在文化、经济层面造成的后果去理解它。
Its political legacy is immense. And how it reshaped the population of the country. So can you just talk us through why it is so devastating? Why it has the impact that it does? And how culpable the British government is in the devastating effects that it has? Okay, and in talking about culpability, you have to be clear that what we're not trying to do here is project back standards and values from a new millennium onto the actions of a government in the middle of the 19th century.
它产生的政治遗产是巨大的。以及它如何重塑了这个国家的人口结构。所以你能给我们讲讲为什么它如此具有毁灭性吗？为什么它会产生如此大的冲击？以及英国政府在其造成的毁灭性影响中负有多大责任？好的，在谈论责任时，你必须明确，我们在这里并不是试图把新千年的标准和价值观强加给19世纪中期政府的行为上。
We must enter that caveat at the beginning. But no, we judge them by the standards of the mid 19th century. Of the period. So the growth of population in Ireland to 8.4 million in 1845 is a massive explosion. And it's an explosion which is driven across the entirety of the West of Ireland and the Midlands and in rural areas by the subdivision of land
我们在开始时必须申明这一点。但是，不，我们要用19世纪中期的标准来评判他们。那个时代的标准。所以，1845年爱尔兰人口增长到840万是一次巨大的暴涨。这是一场横扫整个爱尔兰西部、中部以及农村地区的暴涨，其驱动力是土地的细分
and by the spread and the use of the potato. So about one and a quarter million families were living on farms of fewer than five acres in land, which is exceptionally tiny, tiny, tiny, really small farms, not to call them farms. And these, these were farms and this really matters. These were farms, which were essentially taken and they were tenants of landlords of the 5,000 landlords, more or less, who are Anglo-Irish, are not always so because there are, we have to be very careful not to be absolute on that, but largely speaking, there are 5,000 families who own this land.
以及马铃薯的普及与种植。当时大约有125万家庭生活在不到5英亩的农场上，这块土地极其微小、极其微小、真的非常小，甚至都不能称之为农场。而这些，这些是农场，这真的很重要。这些农场基本上是从大约5000名地主那里租来的，这些地主大多是英爱裔，但也不完全是，因为我们必须非常谨慎，不能绝对化，但大致来说，有5000个家族拥有这些土地。
So by the 1840s, there are about 3 million people who depend on the potato for more than 90% of their calorific intake in any given year. By the way, the potato was not brought to Ireland by Sir Walter Raleigh. It's a product of the exchange of commerce and culture from Ireland and Spain and Britain and everything to do with that. Just say that in passing.
所以在19世纪40年代，大约有300万人在任何特定年份里，其热量摄入的90%以上都依赖马铃薯。顺便说一句，马铃薯并不是由沃尔特·拉利爵士带到爱尔兰的。它是爱尔兰、西班牙、英国之间的商业与文化交流的产物，与此息息相关。顺便提一句。
Blight descended on Europe and in Ireland, hit the potato crop of 1845. That crop lost about half of it was destroyed. extraordinary, just vivid accounts of the smell of rotting potatoes and of the absolute despair of people who put their hand into the soil to pull up a potato plant and to feel that disgusting squelch of rotten potato where it had died in the ground as the withering goes on. The impact then in 1846 was devastating. The entire crop failed. In 1847, there was some improvement, but there was so much limited seed potato available because of the previous two years that not as much had been sold and more was lost. So there's marginal recovery again in 1848, but it was only in 1849 that a normal crop of potatoes was harvested in Ireland. In the course of these four years, and we'll take a few months either side of it and years
枯萎病降临欧洲并蔓延至爱尔兰，摧毁了1845年的马铃薯作物。那季作物大约有一半被毁。非同寻常，有生动的记载描述了马铃薯腐烂的气味，以及人们把手伸进泥土拔出马铃薯植株时那种绝对的绝望——随着枯萎病的蔓延，他们在地下死去的马铃薯中摸到那种令人作呕的粘稠烂泥。随后在1846年，其影响是毁灭性的。整季作物绝收。1847年，情况有所改善，但由于前两年的缘故，可用的优质种薯非常有限，因此种植面积没有那么多，损失也更大。1848年出现了微弱的复苏，但直到1849年，爱尔兰才收获了正常的马铃薯作物。在这四年期间——我们将前后各算几个月和几年
either side of it, about 1 million people died of starvation, of illness. In a country that is the richest in the world. Yes. And about over a million people emigrated. Some emigrated to Liverpool, to that already developing Irish community in Liverpool, or that Irish community along Tottenham Court Road in London. Or some went on ships, later renamed coffin ships, to America and to Canada. They stopped at Grosse Ile or in Ellis Island, and these become extremely important places in Irish history. The Irish emigrants who go to America take with them the absolute conviction
前后——大约有100万人死于饥饿和疾病。在一个世界上最富有的国家。是的。还有超过100万人移民。有些人移民到利物浦，去往利物浦那个已经发展起来的爱尔兰社群，或者伦敦托特纳姆法院路沿线的爱尔兰社群。还有一些人乘坐后来被称为“棺材船”的船只前往美洲和加拿大。他们在格罗斯岛或埃利斯岛停留，这些地方成为了爱尔兰历史上极其重要的地点。去往美洲的爱尔兰移民带去了绝对的信念
that the British are responsible for this. Oh yeah, this really matters. You see it as a deliberate act of genocide. This really matters. So is that true? Well, you have to see what happened during the famine. So the prime ministers who held office during the famine were Sir Robert Peel and Lord John Russell.
英国人对此负有责任。哦，是的，这非常重要。你认为这是一场蓄意的种族灭绝。这非常重要。那么这是真的吗？好吧，你必须看看饥荒期间发生了什么。当时在任的首相是罗伯特·皮尔爵士和约翰·罗素勋爵。
So in the beginning, the government offered for reliance on the provision of employment through public work schemes in Ireland, the building roads, et cetera, the cost of which was to be split between local taxpayers and the central government. And at their height in the spring of 1847, there were about 700,000 people or one in 12 of the population were employed in these schemes. So there's no denying that.
所以在最初，政府依靠在爱尔兰通过公共工程计划提供就业机会，如修建道路等，其费用由当地纳税人和中央政府分摊。在1847年春天的顶峰时期，大约有70万人在这些计划中就业，相当于人口的十二分之一。所以这是无可否认的。
It's kind of like workhouses are operating in England. And the workhouses come into this story in a minute. Then the public work schemes were displaced in 1847 by publicly financed soup kitchens. And these soup kitchens during 1847 were feeding 3 million daily, which is an enormous undertaking. But the government retreated from the provision of those by the October 1847. Every soup kitchen was gone and it was left to the workhouses. And is that because they can't afford it, they say? That was the logic. We're not spending money on this. But is this kind of ideological conviction that it will encourage welfarism? And this is where we get into it. This is where we
这有点像英格兰运作的济贫院。而济贫院稍后也会出现在这个故事中。然后，公共工程计划在1847年被政府出资的粥厂所取代。这些粥厂在1847年每天喂饱300万人，这是一项极其庞大的工程。但政府在1847年10月撤回了对这些粥厂的资助。所有的粥厂都消失了，一切只能依靠济贫院。这是因为他们负担不起吗，他们是这么说的吗？这就是当时的逻辑。我们不会把钱花在这上面。但这是一种意识形态的信念，认为这会助长福利主义吗？这就是我们进入核心问题的地方。这就是我们
get into the weeds of to what extent there's culpability in all of this. So there is an understanding of the gravity of the crisis. And the gravity of the crisis is such that there are bodies such as the Quakers and there are charities who are sending money in arms and they do incredible work. And there is English people who send huge sums of money to help in this. It goes to America where there are Irish emigrants already there
深入探讨这一切中到底负有多大责任的地方。因此，人们对危机的严重性是有认同的。危机的严重性促使贵格会等机构以及慈善机构向爱尔兰汇款和运送武器，他们做了难以置信的工作。还有许多英国人汇巨款来提供帮助。这些钱流向了美洲，那里已经有了爱尔兰移民
because emigration to America was already enormous before the famine. And they are collecting money and the Choctaw Indians most famously made a donation of the equivalent
——认为英国人对此负有责任。哦，是的，这真的很重要。你认为这是一场蓄意的种族灭绝。这真的很重要。那么这是真的吗？好吧，你必须看看饥荒期间发生了什么。所以饥荒期间在任的首相是罗伯特·皮尔爵士和约翰·罗素勋爵。
of about 5,000 pounds. It's the Choctaw Indians who had their own trail of tears from the 1830s. So they send money. So everybody understands through this,
大约5000英镑。这是乔克托印第安人捐赠的，他们在1830年代经历过他们自己的“眼泪之路”。所以他们寄来了钱。因此，每个人都通过这一点明白了，
through the reportage in the newspapers. Nobody can possibly say that they don't know. And the internal British correspondence flowing from Dublin Castle week after week over to England makes clear that there is an extraordinary crisis
通过报纸上的报道。没有人会不知道。都柏林城堡日复一日流向英格兰内部的英国信件清楚地表明，这是一场非同寻常的危机
which is leading to daily death on an epic scale across Ireland during these years. And two aspects of this, which really matters. The first is you have somebody like Charles Trevelyan, who is the chief of famine administrator in Ireland, who expresses desire that permanent good could come out of transient evil. And that's this idea of famine as an austerity measure. And I don't wish to use a trite modern analogy for it, but it's the idea of providence. Right. And the idea that it's Malthusian, basically,
这导致爱尔兰各地在这些年里每天都有大量人口死亡。这里有两个方面非常重要。首先，你有像查尔斯·特里维廉这样的人，他是爱尔兰饥荒的主管官员，他表达了希望“暂时的邪恶能带来永久的善良”的愿望。这就是把饥荒当作紧缩措施的想法。我不想用一个陈腐的现代类比来形容它，但这就是天意的概念。没错。而且这个想法基本上是马尔萨斯主义的，
that a famine will clear out a population to make it more sustainable. And he is the forebearer of Laura Trevelyan, BBC correspondent, who has now given money in reparations to people in the Caribbean because her family had plantations there. And she's talking about doing it with this. And features in one of the most popular Irish ballads, The Fields of Attenrae, where you stole Trevelyan's corn.
即饥荒将清除人口以使其更具可持续性。他是BBC记者劳拉·特里维廉的先辈，她现在已经向加勒比海人民支付了赔偿金，因为她的家族在那里拥有种植园。她正在谈论用这种方式来做这件事。她出现在最受欢迎的爱尔兰民谣之一《阿特恩雷原野》中，歌词唱道：“你偷了特里维廉的玉米”。
Yeah. So the young might see the born. So Trevelyan's corn was understood to be what was taken away. Now, it has to be said there were Irish farmers and Irish businessmen exporting food from Ireland during this thing. This is not a simple narrative and that matters too and must be said. But when it comes down to it, you have the Lord Lieutenant in Ireland writing to the British Prime Minister, Sir John Russell, to say in a letter very clearly, I do not think that there is another legislature in Europe that would disregard such suffering as now exists in the West of Ireland and coldly
是的。所以年轻人可能会看到新生。因此，特里维廉的玉米被理解为被拿走的东西。现在，必须指出的是，在这场事件中，有爱尔兰农民和爱尔兰商人从爱尔兰出口粮食。这不是一个简单的叙事，这一点也很重要，必须说出来。但归根结底，爱尔兰总督写信给英国首相约翰·罗素爵士，信中非常清楚地写道：“我认为欧洲没有哪个立法机构会像现在爱尔兰西部这样无视这种苦难，并冷酷地
persist in a policy of extermination. Now that is the leading British official in Ireland writing to the prime minister. But that thing about a policy of extermination suggests a, I mean, at the very least a genuine desire. I mean, extermination is a big word.
坚持灭绝政策。”现在，那是英国驻爱尔兰的最高官员写给首相的信。但关于“灭绝政策”的说法暗示了，我的意思是，至少是一种真正的愿望。我的意思是，灭绝是个大词。
So the genuine desire among some English or british policymakers you know to pursue the line that you were just describing the idea that this is a necessary providential course that will you know i mean i don't know how they would have put it winnow out the wheat from the chaff or get rid of the dead wood or they would have used some equally kind of horrific expression or would they or are we being unfair i mean is this what they thought that's as baldly as you can see it written what i've just read out to you there back these ideas are current at the time this idea of malthusian ideas of population and what a population can be sustained on a place and what it means to a place to have a population and how much of that so in the last episode we were talking about the 17th century
因此，一些英国或大不列颠决策者之间确实存在这样一种愿望，你知道的，去追求你刚才描述的路线——这种想法认为这是一个必要的天意过程，你知道的，我的意思是，我不知道他们会怎么表达它——大浪淘沙，或者摆脱死木，或者他们会使用同样可怕的表达方式，还是说我们并不公平？我的意思是，这就是他们的想法吗？正如你所能看到的那样，我刚才给你读的东西就这么赤裸裸地写着。这些想法在当时很流行，这种马尔萨斯的人口观念以及一个地方可以维持多少人口，对一个地方来说拥有人口意味着什么，以及其中有多少——所以在上一集里我们在讨论17世纪
and the the stereotypes and the anxieties and that cromwell's troopers took with them when they crossed the irish sea so how much of i mean i guess a lot of people would call it racist wouldn't they how much of that plays into this in other words the fact that the people who are suffering irish does that make the british government's response qualitatively different from if it had been in Yorkshire or in Wales or wherever? Well, I would say that within, to be frank about it, within the ruling classes of Britain at that time, there was a disdain for working people, which can be seen through some of the treatment through the industrial revolution, etc. However, the fact that it was in Ireland matters.
以及克伦威尔的骑兵在跨越爱尔兰海时随身携带的刻板印象和焦虑。那么，这其中有多少——我想很多人会称之为种族主义，不是吗？——有多少因素在起作用？换句话说，受苦的人是爱尔兰人，这是否使得英国政府的反应与如果发生在约克郡、威尔士或其他地方时有着本质的不同？嗯，我要说的是，坦白说，当时英国的统治阶级内部对劳动人民有一种蔑视，这可以通过工业革命期间的一些待遇等看出。然而，发生在爱尔兰这一事实确实很重要。
And it was separated by the sea. It's a different landmass. And there is centuries of just this idea that the Irish are not quite civilized or not civilized at all. And you can see it. It endures through the 19th century. Over the last couple of weeks, I've been going back reading newspapers before you guys came over and looking at Punch for example right so the cartoons
而且它被大海隔开。这是另一片陆块。几个世纪以来，这种“爱尔兰人不够文明或根本不文明”的想法一直存在。你可以看出来。它一直持续到19世纪。在过去的几个星期里，在你们来之前，我一直在回顾报纸，比如看《笨拙》杂志，对吧，也就是漫画
the cartoons in Punch and they bring you into a world of what can only be understood as popular representations of what the Irish were by the way those cartoons
《笨拙》杂志里的漫画，它们把你带入了一个世界，这个世界只能被理解为对爱尔兰人是什么样的人的普遍描绘，顺便说一句，那些漫画
I mean or images like that are still appearing in British tabloid newspapers in the 1970s when people are drawing Republican paramilitaries or something. They're drawing them in exactly the same way as Wild, Savage. Simeonized almost, isn't it? Simeon, exactly. Yeah, absolutely.
我的意思是，诸如此类的形象在20世纪70年代的英国小报中仍然出现，当时人们在画共和派准军事人员或类似的人。他们把他们画得跟野蛮人、未开化的人完全一样。几乎像类人猿一样，不是吗？类人猿，没错。是的，绝对是。
And it is extraordinary when you look back at it and it's jarring. Why there was a recent column by a cartoonist in the London Times, which again, just got a really bad reaction from here because it brought people back to that idea of the representations of the Irish in the British popular press. And it matters though, the famine matters, obviously. And the story of the famine isn't a million dead. It's the story of the famine is people dying on a ditch in the side of the road while they walk to Delphi Lodge looking for food. Yeah. Because they're starving and being turned away and dying on the way back. It's people being tossed over into the Atlantic Ocean where they die on a coffin ship on the way of cross. And it matters for political reasons because it created a community of Irish people who were abroad, who could not be reconciled to the idea of the United Kingdom.
当你回看它时，它是非同寻常的，而且让人感到刺耳。为什么《伦敦时报》最近有一位漫画家的专栏文章，再次在这里引起了非常糟糕的反应，因为它把人们带回了英国通俗报刊中对爱尔兰人描绘的那种想法。不过这很重要，饥荒很重要，显而易见。饥荒的故事并不是一百万人死亡的故事。饥荒的故事是人们在寻找食物前往德尔菲小屋的路上，死在路边的水沟里。是的。因为他们快饿死了却被赶走，并在回程中死去。是人们被抛进大西洋，在横渡的棺材船上死去。出于政治原因，这很重要，因为它创造了一个流亡海外的爱尔兰人社群，他们无法与联合王国的理念达成和解。
And the scale of those numbers of emigration are extraordinary. You see, I had the impression that the aftermath of this coming on top of Cromwell and plantations and everything was that in the wake of the famine, that Irish nationalism was Republican, was virulently Anglophobic was absolutely committed to the overthrow of the union and that this was essentially the easter rising and then the the revolution was expressive of majority opinion in ireland in the wake of the famine and i was kind of amazed to discover that wasn't the case at all that actually the the republican nationalism that ends up founding independent ireland is a very very minority pursuit and that actually majority irish nationalism does accept the functioning of the union it wants home rule it wants a kind of a parliament but one that would
那些移民的数量规模是惊人的。你看，我的印象是，在克伦威尔、种植园和所有这一切之后，饥荒的余波导致爱尔兰民族主义是共和主义的、极其仇英的、绝对致力于推翻联合的，这本质上就是复活节起义，然后革命表达了饥荒之后爱尔兰多数人的意见，而我惊奇地发现根本不是这样的——事实上，最终建立独立爱尔兰的共和民族主义只是极少数人的追求，事实上，多数爱尔兰民族主义者确实接受联合的运作，它想要自治，它想要一个议会，但这个议会将会
be subordinate to the westminster parliament in a weird way the famine leaves a massive political and cultural scar, and one that will never heal, I guess, or one that will never disappear anyway. But why doesn't it lead to greater political... Yeah, because I'm really surprised by that. But why actually is it so quiescent? Is it because the famine is so awful
在某种奇怪的意义上，从属於威斯敏斯特议会。饥荒留下了巨大的政治和文化伤痕，我想，这个伤痕永远不会愈合，或者无论如何永远不会消失。但为什么它没有带来更大的政治……是的，因为我对此感到非常惊讶。但为什么它实际上如此沉寂？是因为饥荒太可怕了吗
that people are too exhausted to... Why isn't there a revolution, an uprising, massive political turbulence where you had chris clark on talking about the rebellions of 1848 there was a rebellion in dublin in 1848 by young irelanders a movement who drew on ideas of a newspaper called the nation and they drew on ideas that exact thing we were talking about earlier about republicanism and romanticism and ideas of ireland and nationality and art and culture and music. And it had no support. It was happening in the
以至于人们精疲力竭……为什么没有爆发革命、起义、大规模的政治动荡？正如你请克里斯·克拉克来谈论1848年叛乱时所说的那样，1848年都柏林发生了一场由“青年爱尔兰党”发起的叛乱，这个运动汲取了一家名为《民族》的报纸的思想，他们汲取了我们刚才谈论的正是关于共和主义、浪漫主义以及爱尔兰、国籍、艺术、文化和音乐的思想。然而它没有得到支持。它发生在
middle of famine and partly that's it. So there is a huge dislocation in Ireland caused by the famine and which endures after the famine. Ireland is the only country in Western Europe, which continued to decline in population for a hundred years after the famine. Ireland is the only country in Western Europe which continued to decline in population for a hundred years after the famine. The rest of the population of Europe,
饥荒之中，部分原因就在于此。因此，爱尔兰因饥荒造成了巨大的社会解体，这种解体在饥荒之后依然存在。爱尔兰是西欧唯一一个在饥荒后的一百年里人口继续下降的国家。爱尔兰是西欧唯一一个在饥荒后的一百年里人口继续下降的国家。欧洲其他地区的人口，
everywhere is exploding. Britain goes in the, what, from 10 million to 40 million in the 19th century. Ireland goes from 8 million to 4 million.
到处都在爆炸性增长。在19世纪，英国人口从1000万增长到4000万。爱尔兰人口从800万下降到400万。
And it continues in free fall. Because of emigration? It's emigration. But just to repeat, I mean, that makes it all the more extraordinary, doesn't it? I agree. But you have to think about it.
并且继续自由落体。是因为移民吗？是移民。但重复一遍，我的意思是，这使得情况更加不同寻常，不是吗？我同意。但你必须考虑一下。
How do you win a rebellion? How do you hold and stage and organize a rebellion that will defeat the largest empire the world has known, who have huge numbers of soldiers garrisoned here? And that is it to presume that you want rebellion, but there are people everywhere who live hand to mouth and who accommodate themselves to an environment in which they find themselves and must live. Well, isn't that the issue that if you're living hand to mouth, the thought of, you know, joining an armed rebellion is so potentially disruptive to your already embattled existence that you just think,
你如何赢得一场叛乱？你如何发起、策划和组织一场能够击败世界上所知最大帝国的叛乱？这个帝国在这里驻扎了大量士兵。这是假设你想要叛乱，但到处都有勉强糊口的人，他们适应了自己所处的并必须生活在其中的环境。嗯，问题不就在于此吗？如果你勉强糊口，那么卷入武装叛乱的想法对于你本已四面楚歌的生存来说具有如此潜在的颠覆性，以至于你会想，
listen, I'm just going to crack on and make the best of it. Is that what it is? That there aren't enough? I think it's a bit of everything. I think it's a bit of everything. There is a revolutionary tradition which runs after 1847.
听着，我还是继续过日子，尽力做到最好吧。是这样吗？是因为人不够多吗？我认为这是各种因素的结合。我认为这是各种因素的结合。1847年之后确实存在一种革命传统。
So to answer your question, there is an attempt to found an Irish Republican Brotherhood, sometimes called the Irish Revolutionary Brotherhood in 1848. And it's founded in Dublin and New York because New York is the biggest Irish city in the world by the middle of the 19th century. And there are people all over the place there who all around the world, you know, 8 million people left Ireland between 1801 and 1921. That's an extraordinary
所以为了回答你的问题，1848年曾尝试建立一个爱尔兰共和兄弟会，有时被称为爱尔兰革命兄弟会。它在都柏林和纽约建立，因为到19世纪中叶，纽约是世界上最大的爱尔兰城市。那里到处都是人，你知道的，从1801年到1921年，有800万人离开爱尔兰。这是一个非同寻常的
figure. But lots of them are going to Britain, right? Oh yeah, a lots of them are going to britain right oh yeah a lot and is that part of what's also going on is that actually the fact that irish people can move to britain because they are citizens of a single kingdom is kind of generating a sense of of the union being something more than just a kind of political expediency i mean is that also part of what's going on but But I think that's inevitable. It's this idea of these ties of kin and commerce, this kind of flow of culture, of education, of jobs, of money. There was a common market between Britain and Ireland from the 1820s onwards. And there was a displacement of Irish industry within that. And the reconstitution of the Irish agricultural experience, for example, and
数字。但他们很多人去了英国，对吧？哦，是的，很多人去了英国，对吧？哦，是的，很多人去了。这也是正在发生的事情的一部分吗？事实上，爱尔兰人可以搬到英国去，因为他们是一个单一王国的公民，这是否正在产生一种感觉，即联合不仅仅是一种政治权宜之计？我的意思是，这也是正在发生的事情的一部分吗？但我认为这是不可避免的。这就是亲属和商业纽带、文化、教育、工作、金钱的这种流动。从1820年代开始，英国和爱尔兰之间就有一个共同市场。其中爱尔兰工业发生了位移。爱尔兰农业经验的重组，例如，以及
Ireland was a profoundly rural country at this stage. Ireland wasn't industrializing the way Britain was. Yes, Belfast was, but the rest of the country was largely speaking, staying in rural areas. It was dependent on clearances from the land of people. So they could raise cattle who were then exported behind us as the river Liffey, 12 sailings a day, bringing live cattle across the Irish sea for slaughter and for sale in the expanding conurbations of the north of England and down into London. So Ireland became a country in which it was deeply dependent on the export trade for agricultural projects to England. So there's that tie as well. And you get
爱尔兰在现阶段是一个深深的乡村国家。爱尔兰没有像英国那样工业化。是的，贝尔法斯特是，但该国其他地区很大程度上仍然停留在农村地区。它依赖于将人们从土地上驱逐出去。这样他们就可以饲养牛，然后把牛运到我们身后的利菲河，每天有12个航次，将活牛运过爱尔兰海，以便在英格兰北部不断扩大的市镇以及伦敦进行屠宰和销售。因此，爱尔兰变成了一个深度依赖对英农业出口贸易的国家。所以也有这种联系。而且你会得到
flows of emigration, money coming back. You still have people organizing though. 1858, they organized Republican Brotherhood. They staged a rebellion in 1867, which is a disaster. They were riddled by informers and it may as well not have happened. In the wake of that, they pass a resolution that they will await the decision of and seems to have acted as a kind of inhibiting factor on the actual plotting of revolution, this resolution for lots of the Irish Republican I'm not sure it had an inhibiting factor. I think it was the idea that you have to have a chance of success. Like 1867 was lost on an epic scale. It was so poor. Presumably one of the consequences of that is that they remain a kind of this tiny minority. And actually the energies of Irish people who are interested in politics goes into something very different, which is a drive for home rule. So I think we should take a break at this point.
移民的流动，资金的回流。不过人们仍然在组织起来。1858年，他们组织了共和兄弟会。他们在1867年发动了一场叛乱，这是一场灾难。他们到处都是密探，这场叛乱简直就像没有发生过一样。在此之后，他们通过了一项决议，即他们将等待……的决定，而这项决议似乎对许多爱尔兰共和党人实际策划革命起到了某种抑制作用。我不确定它是否起到了抑制作用。我认为这是一种必须有成功机会的想法。就像1867年的失败是史诗级的。它是如此糟糕。据推测，其中一个后果是他们仍然保持着这种极少数群体的状态。事实上，对政治感兴趣的爱尔兰人的精力投入到了一件非常不同的事情上，那就是对自治的推动。所以我想我们此时应该休息一下。
And when we come back, let's talk about that, about how the process of home rule, the impact that it has not just on Ireland but on Britain as well. just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the rest of the entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com gladstone spent his declining years trying to guess the answer to the irish question unfortunately whenever he was getting warm the irish secretly changed the question so dominic you will recognize 1066 and all that 1066 and all that published in 1930 so tom i don't want to embarrass you but a few weeks ago when we were talking about this episode there was a sense of dread i think in the holland household because you had very foolishly the idea that home rule was a quite boring and dry topic but now in typical tom holland fashion all over it you've read up on it and you're full of excitement and it's a completely fascinating topic because of the seismic impact it
当我们回来时，让我们谈谈这个，关于自治的过程，它不仅对爱尔兰而且对英国产生的影响。刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、额外单集以及现场门票的早期访问，请前往therestistertainment.com，那是therestistertainment.com。格莱斯顿在他晚年时试图猜出爱尔兰问题的答案，不幸的是，每当他快要答对时，爱尔兰人就会悄悄地改变问题。所以多米尼克，你会认出《1066年及这一类》（1066 and All That），《1066年及这一类》出版于1930年。所以汤姆，我不想让你难堪，但几周前当我们谈论这一集时，霍兰德家里弥漫着一种恐惧感，因为你非常愚蠢地认为自治是一个相当无聊和枯燥的话题，但现在以典型的汤姆·霍兰德方式，你已经完全掌握了它，你读了相关的书，并且充满了兴奋，这是一个完全迷人的话题，因为它的地震般的影响
has on the whole of the united kingdom of great britain and ireland and paul you still with us run off uh out into the streets to look for scenes of cricket matches in the easter rising and so on talk us through the process by which Home Rule becomes the focus of Irish political energies in the second half of the 19th century. I suppose it begs the question, to what extent Irish people were accommodating themselves to empire, or to what extent the empire was so powerful and so ubiquitous in its culture, in the spread of its railways, in everything that flowed, to leave it in a way that you couldn't imagine an alternative reality, that this was Ireland's
它对大不列颠及爱尔兰联合王国整体的影响。保罗，你还在我们身边吗？还是已经跑到街上去寻找复活节起义中的板球比赛场景等等？跟我们讲讲在19世纪下半叶，自治成为爱尔兰政治能量焦点的过程。我想这引发了一个问题：爱尔兰人适应帝国的程度如何？或者帝国在文化上、铁路网的延伸上以及所有涌动的事物中是如此强大和无处不在，以至于你无法想象另一种现实，即这就是爱尔兰的
reality and you should accommodate itself to it. But there is also a sense in which the empire is accommodating itself to Ireland because that passage that I quoted about Gladstone trying to solve the Irish question. I mean, Gladstone is the key figure here because he is the leader of the Liberal Party, which is the hegemonic party for much of this period. And he says, yeah, we accept Home Rule is a cause that we should be getting behind, clearly. But there's also a massive political dimension here, which is there is an Irish parliamentary party. So Ireland has a stake in the empire in a way that no other part of the empire has, right? It has a presence at
现实，你应该去适应它。但也有这样一种感觉，即帝国正在适应爱尔兰，因为我引用的那段关于格莱斯顿试图解决爱尔兰问题的文字。我的意思是，格莱斯顿是这里的关键人物，因为他是自由党的领袖，自由党在这一时期的很大一部分时间里都是霸权政党。他说，是的，我们接受自治是我们应该支持的事业，很明显。但这里还有一个巨大的政治维度，那就是有一个爱尔兰议会党。因此，爱尔兰在帝国中拥有其他任何帝国部分所没有的利益，对吧？它在
Westminster and I don't want to say a powerful lobby, but it has a group that can become powerful based on electoral dynamics. Oh, it's episodically powerful if it's organized in a particular way. It has to be organized and it has to be organized into a party. And that's what happened in the 1870s, where a Home Rule Association, which ultimately became the Irish Parliamentary Party, became the dominant force of the 100 MPs that were sent to the House of Commons in any given year. Now, the 100 MPs, but the way the populations were shifting, meant over-representation in reality of the Irish, but it gave them a presence in Parliament, if it so wished, to put on the agenda the idea of a Home Rule Parliament. So despite the fact that the empire is thriving, despite the fact
威斯敏斯特拥有代表权，我不想说这是一个强大的游说团体，但它拥有一个能够根据选举动态变得强大的集团。哦，如果它以某种特定方式组织起来，它就会间歇性地强大。它必须被组织起来，而且必须被组织成一个政党。这就是1870年代发生的事情，当时自治协会最终成为了爱尔兰议会党，成为在任何给定年份被派往威斯敏斯特下议院的100名议员中的主导力量。现在，这100名议员，但由于人口的转移，实际上意味着爱尔兰人被过度代表了，但如果它愿意的话，这确实让他们在议会中拥有了一席之地，可以将自治议会的理念提上议程。因此，尽管帝国正在蓬勃发展，尽管
that there are these ideas that this is the richest country in the world, there are still a group of people who wish for a separate Parliament under a monarch. The idea of Home Rule that, say, Gladstone signs up to and backing, what would a Home rule have meant? Well, home rule meant a limited amount of powers, for example, not extensive powers of defence, not expensive powers of taxation. It shifted at different stages. You could not say it was independence or you could say it's a distant cousin, but you couldn't say a huge amount more than that. But it was considered by nationalists a stepping stone. Right. So it is seen as a stepping stone. It's not an end point.
存在着这些想法，即这是世界上最富有的国家，但仍然有一群人希望在君主制下拥有一个独立的议会。格莱斯顿签署并支持的自治理念，自治到底意味着什么？嗯，自治意味着有限的权力，例如，不包括广泛的国防权力，不包括广泛的税收权力。它在不同的阶段有所变化。你不能说它是独立，或者你可以说它是它的远亲，但你不能说比这更多。但它被民族主义者视为一个踏脚石。对，所以它被视为一个踏脚石。它不是终点。
It's a stepping stone. There's another thing that really matters. It's a stepping stone. But it also really matters that you can go a long way here to creating a problem for yourself if you imagine that there's a hard wall between revolutionary Irish separatists and the broad suede of the Irish Parliamentary Party, because that's not how it ended up. There are people in the Irish parliamentary party who are Fenians. And remain Fenians, and at different stages.
这只是个跳板。还有另一件真正重要的事情。这只是个跳板。但同样重要的是，如果你认为革命的爱尔兰分离主义者与广大爱尔兰议会党人之间存在一堵坚不可摧的高墙，那么你就在为自己制造巨大的麻烦，因为事情的结局并非如此。爱尔兰议会党里有人是芬尼亚人。而且他们一直是芬尼亚人，在不同的阶段都是如此。
Now, they may age. That may temper the extent of their Fenianism or their desire for revolution. But it is real, and there's a shared space there which is not discreet. The image that the Home Rulers have of a parliament in Dublin, an Irish parliament, their own sense of a degree of self-determination, I mean a limited degree. From the outset, does that take into account that there are a lot of people in the north-eastern corner of Ireland who they know will be unhappy about this because they're Protestants? No, and I'm very cautious here about stepping on Dan Jackson's territory for later on, but it has been one of the great enduring failures
如今，他们可能会变老。这或许会冲淡他们的芬尼亚主义色彩或对革命的渴望。但这是真实存在的，他们之间有一个并非泾渭分明的共享空间。自治派对都柏林议会、爱尔兰议会的构想，以及他们自身对一定程度的自决权的理解——我的意思是某种有限的程度——从一开始，这是否考虑到了爱尔兰东北角有很多人，因为他们是新教徒，所以明知这些人会对此感到不满？没有。而且我在这里非常小心，不想踩到丹·杰克逊稍后要谈的地盘，但爱尔兰民族主义一直有一个长久以来的重大失败——
of Irish nationalism, which arguably is still the case, that there is an underestimate of just how profoundly Ulster Unionists and Loyalists rejected the idea of an independent
而且可以说至今依然如此——那就是严重低估了阿尔斯特统一主义者和忠诚派对独立观念的强烈抵制。
The passage from Wolf Tone, the famous passage that Dominic read at the beginning of this episode, makes reference to the fact that Catholics, Protestants and dissenters are all Irishmen and indeed women. And the passage from the proclamation that you read at the first episode by Patrick Pearce, likewise, massive emphasis on the fact that there will be no kind of sectarian character to this Irish Republic. So they're aware of the problem, but do they just think it's not a massive problem that just by uttering fine sounding sentiments, it will all be solved? It comes down to the impossibility of conceiving of Ireland as anything other than a united island.
沃尔夫·通Tone的段落，也就是多米尼克在本集开头朗读的那段著名文字，提到了天主教徒、新教徒和异见人士全都是爱尔兰人，不论男女。而你在第一集中朗读的帕特里克·皮尔斯的宣言片段，同样极力强调这个爱尔兰共和国绝对不会带有任何宗派色彩。所以他们意识到了这个问题，但他们是不是觉得这根本算不上什么大问题，只要说几句好听的豪言壮语，一切就能迎刃而解了？归根结底，这是因为他们无法将爱尔兰想象成一个统一岛屿之外的任何其他形态。
Problems on the island have been created by the presence of the English stroke British that they have sowed dissent and if they leave, we'll be fine. Number one. Number two, it doesn't really matter if there's a section there who disagree. They're in a minority. Right. And we are the majority and numbers matter. So there we go. And there is no talk of partition on the island before the 1880s. Well, because first of all, you've got to pass home rule, right? So the process by which home rule comes to be brought to the Imperial Parliament in Westminster and then to be rejected. So talk us through that process.
岛上的问题是由英国/英格兰人的存在造成的，是他们播下了分歧的种子，只要他们离开，我们就一切都会好起来。第一。第二，如果有一部分人持反对意见，其实也无所谓。他们只是少数。没错。我们才是多数，而人数至关重要。所以就是这样。在1880年代之前，岛上根本没有人谈论分割。好吧，因为首先你得通过自治法案，对吧？那么，自治法案是如何被提交给威斯敏斯特帝国议会随后又被否决的呢？给我们讲讲这个过程吧。
To talk it through, you have to step out of Parliament and out of parliamentary politics and understand land in Ireland and understand that the land of Ireland was owned not by those who farmed it but by the landlords who made money from the rent that was being paid to them.
要讲清楚这一点，你必须跳出议会和议会政治，去了解爱尔兰的土地问题，并明白爱尔兰的土地不属于耕种它的人，而是属于那些通过收取地租来赚钱的地主。
And who were building all these wonderful houses, stately homes. And we're still talking about maybe 5,000 people or 5,000 families. And you're looking then at a great swale of
还有那些建造了所有这些宏伟宅邸、豪华庄园的人。我们讨论的可能仍然是大约5000人或5000个家庭。然后你会看到一大群——
often very poor people who were farming that land and who were unable to pay rent. And sometimes there were some evictions, but they desired to own their land. And from 1879 onwards, there was first of all, 1879 to 1881, there's what's called a land war led by an unbelievable figure called Michael Davitt, who wrote a brilliant book called The Fall of Feudalism in 1904, which tells the story of the creation of this Irish land leave. And this is the famous introduction of the word boycott, because there's Captain Boycott,
通常非常贫困的人在耕种土地，却无力支付地租。有时会发生驱逐租客的事件，但他们渴望拥有自己的土地。从1879年开始，首先在1879年至1881年期间，发生了一场被称为“土地战争”的运动，领导这场运动的是一个令人难以置信的人物迈克尔·戴维特，他在1904年写了一本名为《封建主义的衰落》的精彩著作，讲述了爱尔兰土地同盟创立的故事。这就是著名的“抵制（boycott）”一词的由来，因为当时有个绰号叫“抵制”的船长——
isn't there, who people refused to pay rents to him or whatever. And so that's where the word boycott comes from. It does. And it's remade. This is a story that's remade around Ireland where local landlords, and there were good landlords, again, in the cartoon version of Irish history, every landlord is evil. But there were good landlords who looked after the Republic, who gave alms during the famine, who were progressive in trying to create a system of agriculture on their lands. But there were others who were absentees. They just took their stuff with them to Westminster and gave nothing in return. And the other thing, I mean, the cartoon version is that the role of the Conservatives in this in Britain, the Tories, is unremittingly negative. But I was amazed to read that actually, what is it, the Wyndham Act of 1903 gave Irish tenant farmers better rights than tenant farmers had anywhere else in the UK. And that this is what a kind of part of a policy on the part of the Conservatives to basically shoot the nationalist foxes to kind of clear up the
对吧？人们拒绝向他支付地租之类的。所以这就是“抵制”这个词的来源。确实如此。这个故事在爱尔兰各地被重新演绎，当地的地主——当然也有好地主，在爱尔兰历史的脸谱化版本中，每个地主都是邪恶的。但也有好地主，他们照顾社区，在饥荒期间施舍救济金，在自己的土地上积极尝试建立农业体系。但也有一些人是缺席地主。他们把所有的东西都带到了威斯敏斯特，却没有任何回报。另外，我的意思是，脸谱化的版本认为英国保守党（即托利党）在这个问题上的角色是全盘负面的。但令我惊奇的是，1903年的《温德姆法案》实际上给予了爱尔兰佃农比英国其他任何地方的佃农更好的权利。这可以说是保守党一项政策的一部分，基本上是为了消除民族主义者的借口，化解——
grievances to kill the desire for home rule with kindness. Yeah, in that great cliche of Irish history, kill home rule with kindness. But the idea of land reform, the first land act is 1881. And the idea is that the country is ablaze and there are agrarian atrocities happening everywhere. There is murder, there is farms being and there are agrarian atrocities happening everywhere. There is murder. There is farms being set alight. There is anti-eviction campaigns going on. It happens again with the Planet Campaign in 1887 into 1888.
各种怨气，用恩惠来消解对自治的渴望。是的，正如爱尔兰历史上的那句名言：用恩惠消解自治。但土地改革的想法，第一部土地法是在1881年。当时的想法是整个国家正处于水深火热之中，各地都在发生土地暴行。有谋杀，有农场被——各地都在发生土地暴行。有谋杀。有农场被纵火。反驱逐运动正在进行。1887年至1888年的“星球计划”运动中，这种情况再次发生。
And you have a complete disconnect in the countryside. And what you have is, first of all, Gladstone converted to the idea of home rule as a way of fix the land question. And as part of that, we need to do something different in Ireland. Ireland is different. There's an acceptance that Ireland is different. It's not Wales and it's not Scotland and it's certainly not Northern England. So we must find a way to do this.
乡村地区出现了严重的脱节。首先是格莱斯顿转变了观念，开始支持自治，以此作为解决土地问题的方法。作为其中的一部分，我们需要在爱尔兰采取不同的做法。爱尔兰是不同的。人们开始接受爱尔兰是不同的这一事实。它不是威尔士，不是苏格兰，也绝对不是英格兰北部。所以我们必须找到一种方法来做到这一点。
So Gladstone puts it onto the books and he tries in 1885 and then into 1886 and it's defeated in the House of Commons through the Tory party who lead a campaign against it and Liberal MPs don't walk with Gladstone. Well he splits his own party Splits his own party, exactly.
于是格莱斯顿将它提上日程，他在1885年尝试，接着在1886年再次尝试，但法案在下议院遭到击败，因为托利党领导了一场反对它的运动，而且自由党议员也没有与格莱斯顿站在一起。他分裂了自己的党派。彻底分裂了自己的党派，没错。
And you go on into the 1890s it's tried again and then this time it's passed by the House of Commons because the Liberals but it's blocked in the Lords. So just on the Lords for a second, just to explain that to our listeners. So obviously Westminster Parliament has two houses, the House of Lords, unelected peers. Now these are, I mean, I don't know what the proportion is, but these are by an absolutely overwhelming majority, conservative peers, not liberals.
到了1890年代，人们再次尝试，这一次法案在下议院通过了，因为自由党人占多数，但在上议院被阻挠了。关于上议院，我们花一秒钟向听众解释一下。威斯敏斯特议会显然有两个院，上议院由非选举产生的贵族组成。这些人的比例我不清楚，但绝大多数绝对都是保守党贵族，而不是自由党人。
There is always this issue of how much they will use their power to block the House of Commons. But of course, a lot of these people are landowners in Ireland, aren't they? So they have a dog in the fight. They have a vested interest. I mean, they're not just conservative peers. They are intensely conservative peers, many of them. Yes. And it matters in a different way, actually, when we come on to the opposition to Home Rule for Ireland after 1912, when that's all tied into the super tax of the rich, which is so much a part of post people's budget, British political culture and the divide extraordinary when you read those debates in the House of Commons, just how vitriolic those divides came. It begins in the 1880s with the idea of Home Rule for Ireland led by Charles Stuart Parnell,
他们总是面临这样一个问题：他们会在多大程度上利用自己的权力去阻挠下议院。但当然，这些人当中有很多都是爱尔兰的地主，对吧？所以他们在这场博弈中有着自身的切身利益。他们拥有既得利益。我的意思是，他们不仅仅是保守党贵族。其中许多人是极其顽固的保守党贵族。是的。事实上，当我们谈到1912年后对爱尔兰自治的反对时，情况就变得大不相同了，这一切都与富人的超级税收交织在一起，而超级税收正是后来的“人民预算”、英国政治文化以及巨大分歧的重要组成部分。当你阅读下议院的那些辩论时，你会惊叹于这些分歧竟然变得如此充满恶毒。这一切始于1880年代，由查尔斯·斯图尔特·帕内尔领导的爱尔兰自治运动——
his statue at the top of the street here. So it's O'Connell at one end and it's Charles Stuart Parnell at the far end with Nelson gone from the middle. But Parnell is what I, that's because Joyce was obsessed by him. He is the kind of the great leader of the uncrowned king of Ireland, the uncrowned king of Ireland, the Irish parliamentary party in Westminster and working cahoots with Gladstone and then he has this scandalous affair with, in Joyce, she's called Kitty O'Shea Catherine O'Shea. You can't call her Kitty O'Shea Tom, that's a terrible faux pas. Well I'm merely quoting Joyce there and Gladstone refuses
他的雕像就在这条街的尽头。所以一头是奥康奈尔，另一头是查尔斯·斯图尔特·帕内尔，中间的纳尔逊雕像已经不见了。但帕内尔就是我——那是因为乔伊斯对他着迷。他是爱尔兰无冕之王的某种伟大领袖，爱尔兰无冕之王，爱尔兰议会党在威斯敏斯特的核心人物，与格莱斯顿勾结合作，然后他与——在乔伊斯的作品中，她被称为基蒂·奥谢（Kitty O'Shea），凯瑟琳·奥谢——发生了丑闻。汤姆，你不能叫她基蒂·奥谢，这是一个严重的失礼。好吧，我只是在引用乔伊斯的话。而格莱斯顿拒绝——
to work with him because he's an adulterer which is very Gladstonian behaviour. It is the story of Parnell and known as Parnell, called himself Parnell. There was a brilliant documentary on RT Radio where they talked to somebody who was a groundskeeper when Parnell was there. And he talked about how he called him Parnell. And it was a recording from the 20s, possibly the 30s. consultation got support and blurred that line between the Irish Republican Brotherhood and the Irish Parliamentary Party to present himself as the dominant figure in Irish politics
与他合作，因为他是个通奸者，这非常符合格莱斯顿式的行为。这就是帕内尔的故事，被称为帕内尔，他自称为帕内尔。RT电台曾播放过一个精彩的纪录片，他们采访了帕内尔在世时的一位球场看护员。他谈到自己是怎么称呼帕内尔的。那是一段20年代或30年代的录音。协商获得了支持，并模糊了爱尔兰共和兄弟会与爱尔兰议会党之间的界限，使他把自己塑造为爱尔兰政治中的主导人物——
and got Gladstone to agree to Home Rule. By the way, amazing decade if you look at it, 1882, the two leading British officials in Ireland were murdered by Republicans when they walked in the Phoenix Park murders. Like a really shocking, leading to the creation of the special branch and that development in that part of policing. Number one. Number two, there were bombs sent into Downing Street later in the decade. So the revolutionaries are still there, even if some of them are part of the Home Rule movement. And so Parnell, there's a huge attempt to undermine Parnell as the decade moves on. So there are forgeries used to discredit him and claim that he was always a violent man, really, and that he's really a Fenian dressed up as a politician. a scandal which flows from Catherine O'Shea, whose husband, Captain O'Shea, was an Irish MP. And what it ignores, of course, is that this was something that had been going on throughout the
并让格莱斯顿同意了自治。顺便说一句，如果你回顾一下，1882年是一个惊人的十年，当时爱尔兰的两名主要英国官员在菲尼克斯公园散步时被共和党人谋杀。这是一起极其令人震惊的事件，导致了特别支部的创建以及该领域警务的发展。第一。第二，这十年晚些时候，还有炸弹被寄进唐宁街。所以革命者依然存在，尽管他们中的一些人也是自治运动的一部分。因此，随着这十年过去，出现了试图破坏帕内尔声誉的巨大尝试。有人利用伪造的文件来抹黑他，声称他一直是个暴力分子，实际上是一个伪装成政治家的芬尼亚人。一场由凯瑟琳·奥谢引发的丑闻爆发了，她的丈夫奥谢船长是一名爱尔兰议员。当然，这其中被忽视的是，这种情况在整个——
1880s. They were essentially living together. They had two daughters together. And it was only when there was a dispute over a bequest and the sharing of bequests between Catherine O'Shea and Captain O'Shea that it emerged into the public. And what you had immediately was the forces of people who opposed Home Rule. They could come straight into the middle and they split the party. And you have things like Archbishop Thomas Croke, the most important Catholic cleric in Ireland in the 19th century, describing Parnell as the measly runt who infected the litter. And you have the party split down the middle where you have some people who stay with Parnell, but the majority go against them. And he goes chasing this in an election campaign and he drives himself around the country and he drives himself basically to death.
1880年代一直在发生。他们实际上一直生活在一起。他们有两个女儿。直到凯瑟琳·奥谢和奥谢船长之间就遗产遗赠和遗产分配产生纠纷时，这件事才公之于众。随之而来的是，反对自治的力量立刻涌现出来，他们直接介入其中并导致了党派的分裂。当时的爱尔兰天主教会十九世纪最重要的神职人员托马斯·克罗克大主教甚至将帕内尔描述为“感染了全窝的瘦弱幼崽”。党派从中分裂成两派，一部分人留下来支持帕内尔，但大多数人选择反对他。他带着这一切去参加竞选，驱车走遍全国，基本上把自己累死了。
And the fall of Parnell is kind of a salutary tale on the whole of religion and Irish politics. And his funeral though is one of the most extraordinary sights at the end of 19th century.
帕内尔的倒台堪称一部关于整个宗教与爱尔兰政治的警世寓言。不过他的葬礼是19世纪末最震撼的景象之一。
There's 2,000 men walking with hurleys, hurling sticks, the symbol of Irish nationalism, as well as being a sporting implement, draped in black crepe paper. It's one of those things that those images which is held and he's walked through and he's lamented as this figure. And in the world of Yeats, Tom, that you mentioned earlier, it leads in his view to a turning away from politics and a resurgence of an interest in culture, which ultimately leads him to ask, 30 or 40 years later,
有两千名男子手持爱尔兰hurleys（一种投掷棍棒，是爱尔兰民族主义的象征，也是一项运动器材），上面披着黑色的绉纱。这正是那些被人们铭记的画面之一，人们护送着他，哀悼这位传奇人物。在汤姆你刚才提到的叶芝的世界里，在他看来，这导致人们对政治转向冷漠，并重新燃起对文化的兴趣，这最终促使他在三四十年后发出这样的疑问：
did that play of mine send out certain men the English shot? So Paul, two Home Rule bills fail, and we're now into the 20th century. Home Rule is still kind of on the agenda, but you have a massive liberal landslide in 1906. So actually, the liberals are now back in, split themselves over Home Rule, opening the door to 20 years of Tory hegemony. Then the liberals are back in, but they don't need the Irish Parliamentary Party to do that. They've got a massive majority. So Home Rule, they don't really care about Home Rule. I mean, Asquith and co, they're not massively signed up to it as gladstone was i mean it's fascinating because of developments in british politics because they fall out with
我写的那出戏剧，是否曾送出某些被英国人枪决的年轻人？所以，保罗，两项自治法案都失败了，我们现在进入了20世纪。自治仍然在某种程度上被提上日程，但在1906年，自由党取得了压倒性的胜利。因此，自由党实际上又回来了，他们曾因自治问题而分裂，从而为长达20年的托利党统治敞开了大门。随后自由党卷土重来，但他们不需要爱尔兰议会党的支持就能做到这一点。他们拥有压倒性的多数。所以自治，他们其实并不怎么关心自治。我的意思是，阿斯奎斯等人，他们并不像格莱斯顿那样坚定地支持自治。这很迷人，因为英国政治的发展导致他们与——
the house of lords by the tories about their own economic and kind of social welfare plans they're regarded as revolutionaries by the tories the liberals there are two elections they lose their majority effectively now they're dependent on the Irish Parliamentary Party. And now Home Rule is back on the agenda with a vengeance. The dream scenario for the Irish Parliamentary Party is exactly this. The Liberals and the Conservatives are stuck on almost exactly the same number of seats after two elections. And there is the kingmaker in John Redmond, who was a Parnellite in the 1890s, stuck with him after the split, the Irish parliamentary party split, was divided for
托利党因自身的经济和社福计划而在上议院产生矛盾，他们被托利党视为革命者。自由党经历了两次选举，实际上失去了多数席位，现在他们开始依赖爱尔兰议会党。如今，自治带着复仇的怒火重新回到了议程上。对爱尔兰议会党而言，最完美的剧本正是如此。经过两次选举后，自由党和保守党所获得的席位数量几乎完全相同。而约翰·雷德蒙（John Redmond）则成了掌握生杀大权的造王者。他在1890年代曾是帕内尔派，在党内分裂后依然追随帕内尔。爱尔兰议会党分裂了十年，如今在雷德蒙的领导下重新统一。但问题在于他们会怎么做。雷德蒙，汤姆，你刚才提到了温德姆法案，它与1903年和1909年的法案一起，是非凡的姿态和尝试，在爱尔兰引入了对地主所拥有的土地的强制收购，并使其被出售给佃农。这些土地最初由保守党重新分配，随后又通过奥古斯丁·比雷尔（Augustine Birrell）推动的土地法得到了补充。
10 years, reunited under Redmond. But the question is what they would do. Now, Redmond, Tom, you mentioned earlier the Wyndham Act, which on top of the 1903 and the 1909 Acts, are extraordinary gestures and attempts introducing compulsory purchase of landlord-held land in Ireland and making it be sold to the tenant farmers. It's redistributed by the Tories initially and then topped up by Augustine Burrell's driving of the alien rights.
而约翰·雷德蒙基本上是……所以奥古斯丁·比雷尔是自由党在都柏林的代表。是的，他是首席秘书，内阁成员，来到爱尔兰。这就是我们谈到约翰·雷德蒙的地方。约翰·雷德蒙是一个迷人的人物。他是爱尔兰议会党的领袖。他是取代帕内尔的人，但在很大程度上被爱尔兰民族主义历史所抹去了。他的雕像并不在奥康奈尔街上，
And John Redden was essentially... So Augustine Burrell is the liberal representative in Dublin. Yes, he's the chief secretary, sits in the cabinet, comes over. And so this is where we get into John Redmond. So John Redmond is a fascinating figure. He's the head of the Irish parliamentary party. He's the man who's replaced Arnell and has been largely written out of Irish nationalist history. His statue is not on O'Connell Street,
尽管他是最终将自治法案写进法律条文的自治领袖，尽管这并没有什么实质意义。他曾是英国政治中的造王者，而现在却被英国历史完全抹去了。我们在第一集里讨论过这一点。我很惊讶约翰·雷德蒙竟然没有出现在你们所受的历史教育中，鉴于他在——
despite the fact that he is the Home Rule leader who got the Act eventually onto the statute books, even if it didn't mean anything. And a kingmaker in British politics who's now being completely written out of British history. We talked about this in the first episode. I'm astonished that John Redmond is not part of the teaching that you got because of his seminal role
推动1911年《议会法案》方面所起的关键作用，该法案基本上限制了上议院阻止法案的时间，这对自治产生了巨大影响。所以给我们讲讲这个过程吧。我来接上这个。关于这一点，正如我在录音前对你说的，在我大约18年作为一个历史迷的中学生涯中，
in allowing for the Parliament Act of 1911, which basically limited the amount of time that the House of Lords could stop a bill, which had huge implications for Homeworld. So talk us through that. I'll pick that. Just one thing on that. Just as I think I said to you before we were recording, in 18 years or so as a history-obsessed schoolboy,
我想我从来没听过“约翰·雷德蒙”这个名字，甚至连它的文字都没见过。我的意思是，他根本不属于……这一切根本不属于英国关于自身的叙事对吧，汤姆？我的意思是，你在英国可能会对历史非常感兴趣，但对于你的意识来说，这完全是一个黑洞。不过话虽如此，我认为人们有一种感觉，即在第一次世界大战爆发前的几年里，与爱尔兰政治相关的某种不祥之兆正在酝酿。我觉得确实有这种感觉，但我觉得它太复杂了，我实在是理不清头绪。我只知道事情正在走向崩溃。我们会讨论这个话题的，
I don't think I ever heard the words John Redmond or even saw them written down. I mean, he's just not part of the... This whole thing is not part of the this whole thing is not part of britain's story of itself is it tom at all i mean you could be really interested in history in britain and this would simply be a black hole as far as your consciousness is concerned although having said that i think that there is a sense that something ominous is brewing connected with irish politics in the years that build up to the Great War. I think there is that sense, but I think it's so complicated that I can't really get my head around it. I just know that things are heading towards a smash. We will be talking about this,
但由于爱尔兰的危机，以及英国政客在英国如何处理这场危机、他们在这些年里选择做什么，不仅是爱尔兰，连英格兰也被拖向了内战边缘，这不仅对爱尔兰，对英国也是至关重要的。
but England, not just Ireland, but England was being pulled to civil war by virtue of the crisis in Ireland and how that crisis was dealt with in England by British politicians and what they chose to do during these years is hugely important, not just for Ireland, but for Britain.
其中发生的一些事，让脱欧后的那些政治把戏看起来简直毫无意义、无关紧要。议会的休会，司法领域的种种事情，都变得无关紧要。是的。
And some of the stuff that went on makes the shenanigans post-Brexit look utterly meaningless and irrelevant. The proroguing of parliament, the stuff in the judiciary, irrelevant. Yeah.
除了当前兵变事件的规模——这只是其中一例，我们稍后会再谈到它。所以约翰·雷德蒙，我的意思是，他梦想着自治，这是他的机会。他是帕内尔之后的领袖，他与自由党首相阿斯奎斯一起，全力推动第三次自治法案。现在情况变得很复杂——正如汤姆所说，这是一个非常复杂的故事。但是因为英国的预算问题和那里的斗争——被自由党视为革命性的福利国家立法，以及围绕此事的巨大的宪法冲突，
Besides the scale of the current mutiny to name but one thing and we'll come back to this so john redmond who is i mean he he dreams of home rule this is his chance he's been the leader post parnell and he and asquith the liberal prime minister so they go for the third home rule bill now complicating i mean such as thomas is a very complicated story. But because of the stuff about the budget in Britain and the fight over there, what's seen as the liberals' revolutionary kind of welfare state legislation, and because of the massive constitutional ructions around that,
保守党人将自由党视为一种革命性的、几乎是非法的政府。保守党领袖安德鲁·博纳·劳（Andrew Bonar Law）形容一个其实赢得了三次选举的政府——描述他们为“一个通过欺诈夺取专制权力的革命委员会”。是的。这里的专制权力是指他们基本上——因为国王已经——很难说他是站在哪一边，他没有完全站在自由党一边，但为了寻求妥协，他们确实——哦，他确实这么做了，多米尼克。
the conservatives regard the liberals as a kind of revolutionary, almost illegitimate government. Andrew Bonalloy, the leader of the Conservative Party, regards the liberals as a kind of revolutionary, almost illegitimate government. Andrew Bonalloy, the leader of the Conservative Party, described a government which had won three elections, by the way, described them as a revolutionary committee which has seized by fraud upon despotic power. Yeah. And the despotic power here is that they basically, because the king has, it's hard to say he's sided with, he hasn't quite sided with the liberals, but in an attempt to find a compromise, they have. Oh, he did, Dominic.
我想你可以说他确实这么做了。他站在了自由党一边。因为他向——为了让人们明白，上议院为什么要通过一项将其实质否决权限制在三年而不是绝对否决权的法律？他们为什么要这么做？他们这样做的唯一原因，是因为阿斯奎斯收到了国王的消息，称国王将向上议院注入大量新议员。是的，用自由党贵族充实上议院。用自由党贵族。因此，保守党贵族认为，好吧，我们最好接受这个妥协，否则我们将彻底失去权力。
I think you can say he did. He sided with the liberals. Because he gave, just so people understand, why would the House of Lords pass a law which would limit its powers of veto to three years rather than making it absolute? Why would they do that? And the only reason they did it was because Asquith received from the king from news that he would flood the House of Lords. Yeah, with liberal peers. With liberal peers. Therefore, conservative peers took the view, well, we better take this compromise or we lose power entirely.
所以简单来说，基本上发生的情况是，上议院对自治的否决权在很大程度上被剥夺了。因此，实际上，阿斯奎斯和雷德蒙可以梦想——如果“梦想”这个词合适的话——这样一个世界：爱尔兰自治法案将在下议院通过，上议院最终也会批准它。这就引发了一个问题——
So just to simplify it, so basically what's happened is that the House of Lords' veto power over Home Rule has been largely removed. So now, actually, Asquith and Redmond can dream, if dream is the right word, of a world in which an Irish Home Rule Bill will get through the House of Commons, the House of Lords will eventually approve it. And that then raises the issue of
爱尔兰实际上有人不希望通过自治法案。嗯，这是一笔交易。这远超他们的梦想。他们达成了一笔交易。雷德蒙将支持《议会法案》。雷德蒙之前支持过——
there are actually people in Ireland who don't want the Home Rule Bill. Well, it's a deal. It's more than they can dream of it. They've done a deal. Whereas Redmond will support the Parliament Act. Redmond previously supported
“人民预算”，尽管它增加了爱尔兰酒类许可证的成本并对饮酒征税等等，这在爱尔兰的酒店老板中并没有受到欢迎，而酒店老板是爱尔兰议会党在各地的重要基础。
the people's budget, even though it increased things like the cost of having drink licenses in Ireland and put a tax on drinking, etc., etc., which did not play well with the publicans of this island, who are fundamental to the Irish Parliamentary
它还引入了社会福利法案和老年养老金等政策，这对雷德蒙认为的爱尔兰财政部来说，带来了巨大的长期成本。因此，为了换取在1912年引入自治法案、将自治权赋予爱尔兰的协议，他吞下了自己并不想支持《议会法案》的苦果。但据我所知，该法案于1912年被提出。根据这项新法案的条款，政府必须以完全相同的措辞三次重新提出该法案，然后它才能通过。届时上议院将不再能够阻止它。
Party around the place. And it introduced things like Social Welfare Act and old age pensions, which had a huge long-term cost for what Redmond thought would be an Irish exchequer. So he swallowed things he didn't want to support the Parliament Act in a deal that there would be a Home Rule Bill brought in in 1912, giving Home Rule to Ireland. But as I understand it, the bill is brought in in 1912. By the terms of this new Act, the government has to reintroduce the bill three times in exactly the same phrasing, and then it's passed. Then the House of Lords can no longer block it.
所以通过在1912年提出它，他们基本上是在说它将在1915年通过。它将在1915年成为法律。不，是在1912年4月提出。这是第一次。1913年4月再次提出，然后是1914年4月。好的。所以现在爱尔兰终于拥有自治的可能性了。立法机制可以说是已经准备好了。
So by introducing it in 1912, they're basically saying it will be passed in 1915. It will become law in 1915. No, bring it in in 1912, April 1912. That. They're basically saying it will be passed in 1915. It will become law in 1915. No, bring it in in 1912, April 1912. That's the first way. It goes again in April 1913, but then it's April 1914. Okay. So now the possibility is there for Ireland at last to have home rule. The legislative mechanism has been, as it were, prepared.
但爱尔兰有一群人，不仅仅是他们不想要自治，而是他们对此坚决反对，并准备拿起武器进行反抗。哦，他们准备拿起武器了。我知道丹接下来要谈论这种不统一的想法，以及自治的想法对英国社会产生的影响。我们在爱尔兰喜欢认为它只影响了爱尔兰社会，但当然，当时人们对帝国有着巨大的人气热情，他们社会的繁荣是以这个帝国为根基的。阿尔斯特以及阿尔斯特内部的人们与其他人有着联系，那里的人们正在走向繁荣，他们将这种繁荣和他们的自由视为与留在联合王国之内密不可分。他们绝不容忍任何会改变或削弱他们在联合王国中地位的举措。同样，自由党人和爱尔兰议会党人也完全没有理解这种情感的深度。保罗，你刚才提到了这些词，所以谈论它绝对不是夸大其词。在1912年这个时间点，可以说，
But there are a group of people in Ireland who are, it's not just they don't want home rule, they are vehemently opposed to it and they are prepared to take up arms to fight against it. Oh, they're prepared to take up arms. And I know Dan is going to talk about the idea of this unity and the impact that the idea of home rule
英国和爱尔兰正合乎逻辑地走向内战吗？哦，这真是一个惊人的断言：萨拉热窝事件实际上被赫伯特·阿斯奎斯形容为他职业生涯中遇到的最幸运的事情。太棒了。那么汤姆，我们下次还会回来，对吧？不是和保罗，而是和另一位嘉宾、节目的老朋友丹·杰克逊一起，他将讨论自治危机、对英国的影响，以及我们距离内战有多近。然后保罗会回来谈论复活节起义。所以最后，汤姆，我们将回到我们在第一集开篇时提到的那个宣言。
had on British society. We in Ireland like to think it just affected Irish society, but of course it was a huge popular enthusiasm for empire and the prosperity of their society being based, rooted in this empire. And there were connections with people in Ulster and within Ulster, there were people who were prospering and they saw that prosperity and their
保罗，非常感谢你。我们期待着不久后与你讨论复活节起义。这是我的荣幸。再见。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听独家节目、提前收听、无广告收听并加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。
freedom as being intrinsically linked to the idea of remaining part of the United Kingdom. They could not countenance any measure that would change or dilute their position within the United Kingdom. And again, there was a failure on the Liberal behalf and an absolute failure in the Irish Parliamentary Party to understand just the depth of that feeling. And Paul, you mentioned these words earlier on, so it's not an exaggeration to talk of it. At this point in 1912, it's fair to say, is it,
这就是 restishistorypod.com。这就是 restishistorypod.com。感谢收听。
that Britain and Ireland are heading plausibly towards civil war? Oh, it is some statement to say that events in Sarajevo actually were said by Herbert Asquith wrote that they were the luckiest thing that happened in his career. Great. So Tom, we'll be back next time, won't we? Not with Paul, but with a different guest, friend of the show, Dan Jackson, who will be talking about the Home Rule crisis, the implications in Britain, how close we came to civil war. And then Paul will be back to talk about the Easter Rising. So finally, how close we came to civil war. And then Paul will be back to talk about the Easter Rising. So finally, Tom, we'll get back to the proclamation
英国和爱尔兰正合乎情理地走向内战？哦，这真是一个惊人的说法，赫伯特·阿斯奎夫曾写道，萨拉热窝事件实际上是他职业生涯中遇到的最幸运的事情。太好了。汤姆，我们下次还会回来，对吧？不是和保罗一起，而是和另一位嘉宾、节目的老朋友丹·杰克逊一起，他将讨论地方自治危机、对英国的影响以及我们离内战有多近。然后保罗会回来谈论复活节起义。所以最后，我们离内战有多近。然后保罗会回来谈论复活节起义。最后，汤姆，我们将回到宣言
with which we began the first episode. So Paul, thank you so much. And we look forward to speaking to you very shortly about the Easter Rising. My pleasure. Goodbye. Bye-bye. Goodbye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com.
我们就是从第一集开始的。保罗，非常感谢你。我们期待着很快就能和你聊聊复活节起义。我的荣幸。再见。拜拜。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听独家节目、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。
That's restishistorypod.com. That's rest launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那是 restishistorypod.com。那是 rest 推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果您想享受无广告收听、独家节目和提前购买现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。